[Music]
so first just swing the way past your
toes and what you're gonna do you know I
have my big tree but you've got whatever
you've got over there your feet are
gonna stay you're just going to turn
your body in that direction as the play
past your toes I'm asking to put the
play in the backwards so they're on a
plane in front of you and then you turn
and look like scooping the backwards so
I want you to try to do that using
mostly just the movement of your body
your attorney and let your arms be quite
relaxed and with a little practice you
may be letter to a nice breath you'll
find that the turning of your body does
the work for you if you start with the
play forward so now I've got my play
going forwards dynamite gazebo and just
find that moment in the park coming down
in front of you when you turn all the
way and the turning itself the play at a
backwards same thing as a player coming
up if I turn all the way to my right
shoulder I'm back at the gazebo so I
want you to Pratt you know the move now
but what I want you to practice is doing
it with this little unnecessary movement
as possible you turn the car going
forwards as if coming down find that
moment when the turn does the work for
you inside if you turn and then do the
movement or the tube movement and then
they'll turn and that's all I know Cerie
okay now we'll learn the same thing
behind us put the point here and really
feel the position your hands are the
same height they are shoulder width
apart behind your shoulders and feel
them when when the poi are passing your
butt and you can even lean back a little
bit to have this feeling of being the
poi on a plane behind you so I say pass
your butt you can turn and that'll
naturally put the boy into forwards then
you turn pass the toes and here's the
trick from here what I want you to do
for a little while is just get
back to this position and don't try to
get here right away
just try to get to here because I want
you to your body to get used to the
hands being this position because a lot
of beginners what they'll start putting
do things like this we're one hands way
higher in all these awkward positions
and I want you to pass right through
this so you go to forwards past your
toes and then get back to your butt
forwards past your toes and then back to
your butt you can also go the other way
get it going backwards now we switch
directions here so now I'm up the gazebo
it's my butt the forwards past the toes
I'll figure zebra to my butt damn tree
past my toes and what I want you to do
is as it's coming up instead of bringing
it way in front of you and then getting
it behind really wait for it to be
behind to go to pasture but because this
the player behind you wait for them to
be behind you to do the turn and that's
going to mean a lot less unnecessary
movement because if you bring a boy
weight - if I bring a boy to the lake
and then try to get them behind me
that's going to be pretty awkward so as
you're coming up I'm already that I'm
gonna come onto this plane a little bit
like if there's a wall here the left boy
comes and joins the right point on that
wall and so it would be very unnecessary
to have the right play during the left
boy on front and then both behind that's
a lot of movement and then just start to
loop it past about past the toes
pass the buck us the toast make them a
little bit short around a couple fingers
for this turn I want you to start here
and think you're gonna go one two and
three wait for me behind you to do the
turn so a lot of people do is they do
they do this they turn to the play in
front of them and then they try to get
the play behind them and that's really
tough so what you're going to do is
you're going to wait for the play to be
behind behind behind and turn and then
what yet I'm spinning and you go behind
and turn and you can really raise a boy
up behind you as you turn so they raise
up and if you want you can change the
direction let's get a swing forwards
here same thing you're gonna go one two
three and turn rainbow and then from
spinning behind the Nuba turn behind
behind of the shoulders behind the hips
you get a good foundation going now vask
is what's going to let you then put it
all together smoothly once you've
practice all the variables and the next
video we'll talk about making sure
you're practicing all variables
[Music]